Першими повідомлення про масштабну кібератаку
почали надходити з України.
Були паралізовані сервери "Укртелекому", "Укрзалізниці",
націорнальної пошти, аеропортів "Бориспіль" і  Жуляни,
низки банків і держустанов.
Хакерам вдалося атакувати
такий важливий стратегічний об'єкт,
як Чорнобильська АЕС.
Трохи більше місяця тому
схожий вірус-вимагач WannaCry
паралізував мільйони комп’ютерів у різних куточках світу.
Тоді ж експерти застерігали
щодо нової атаки і давали низку порад,
як уникнути нового зараження.
Вірус вражає комп'ютер, коли юзер відкриває сумнівний лінк
у повідомленні електронної пошти.
Тож порада номер один - не відкривайте мейли з невідомих адрес.
Найбільш вразливі - комп’ютери з піратським софтом.
Тому порада номер два -
користуйтеся ліцензійними версіями.
Програмне забезпечення, яке вже давно не оновлювалося, може містити дірки,
через які "пролізе" вірус. Тому порада номер три -
регулярно оновлюйте програмне забезпечення.
А також робіть резервні копії всіх критично важливих даних.
Вірус зашифровує інформацію на комп’ютері
й виводить на екран вимогу сплатити "викуп" -
300 доларів у біткоїнах.
Якщо на вашому компютері з'явився цей напис, слід відключити інтернет.
Можливо, вірус ще не встиг зашифрувати ваші файли.
Інакше доведеться форматувати диски
і ставити нову операційну систему.
Експерти радять не платити викуп: файли, скоріш за все, ви вже не повернете,
а лише заохотите подальші хакерські атаки.